in this troubled and extraordinarily
stupid age we can always count on two
things come summertime one is that we'll
be told by the media and various
hectoring voices on the internet that
global warming is to blame for the high
temperatures and
um the you know thousands across the
world are dying because of it and the
other is that those same people in the
media and those same hectoring voices
will insist that although we are all
allegedly boiling to death
we must not use air conditioning because
air conditioning is evil
why is it evil well the fun thing is to
find out what reasons they'll give
at any given time
all they know to begin with is that air
conditioning exists
and it was invented by a white person
and it makes people happy
and it makes life more enjoyable and so
it must be bad
the writer eric dean wilson is one of
the latest to take a stab at explaining
why air conditioning is a form of
sorcery he wrote a whole book on the
subject actually published in july
titled
after cooling on freon global warming
and the terrible cost of comfort
now i can't tell you exactly what the
book says because i'd rather be
decapitated by a butter knife than read
it but i did skim a seattle times
interview with the author and the first
question in that interview i'm not
making this up the first question is
how was the public sold on the idea that
feeling comfortable was okay
yeah how dare the public feel
comfortable especially without asking
eric dean wilson first
well walt wilson explains that comfort
is a capitalist conspiracy and then he
goes on to talk about how air
conditioning has increased racial
inequality has become and i quote a
pretty insidious tool for racial
segregation
it's also destroying the planet and
causing temperatures to rise he insists
now here i am stupid enough to think
that the giant ball of gas in the sky
burning at 27 million degrees and
exerting enough gravitational force to
influence objects floating in space 12
trillion miles away is really the driver
of temperature and climate on our puny
planet but i'm wrong again
your hvac unit is really responsible
so air can air conditioning is racist
and it's killing the planet it's also
sexist we uh we've been told the writer
taylor lorenz has described air
conditioning as unhealthy bad miserable
and sexist
many other female writers have joined
the chorus explaining that
air conditioning is a misogynistic uh
plot basically uh because women
tend to feel cold
and ac units and offices are often set
at temperatures that are uncomfortable
for the fairer sex
now that may be generally true but look
sorry ladies you need to suck it up on
this one because if you're cold here's
here's the way this breaks down
if you're cold you can always put on a
sweater
if i'm hot
i can only take off so many items of
clothing before you start calling the
police
so this is why the warmest person in the
home or in the office gets to decide
where the ac is set
those are the rules i didn't make them
up well i did make them up but even so
they are the rules
but we aren't done yet a recent viral
video brings us back to the racist
element of air conditioning and let's uh
let's hear how they make the case here
it is so many reasons i can think of off
the top of my head why americans are
addicted to air conditioning so many
reasons but the most infuriating one is
that our buildings are built wrong in a
great stitch desired stevens talked
about how it was because of white
supremacy and colonialism indigenous
people had air conditioning through
streams of water built underneath the
ground or in ways that worked with
natural landscapes such as building in
the shade and there are so many more
examples from what we call vernacular
architecture for example wind catchers
from iran a famously hot place these
were incredibly effective cooling
systems these traditional malay houses
are designed to be porous that allow for
cross ventilation here's another
self-ventilating house from southern
turkey so if the colonizers had not
killed everybody and learned how they
could naturally cool their buildings we
might not need air conditioning so when
you all are like oh it doesn't matter
the field of architecture is based in
white supremacy it's still like great
design
it's bad design because we have to burn
oil to not get heatstroke to live in
this stupid building because you will
respect vernacular architecture
okay so let me uh interject a few things
here
first why are americans addicted to air
conditioning well because it's great
it's wonderful it's it is one of the
objectively good superior things about
modern society
it is one modern invention that actually
has no downside
the only downside to air conditioning is
if you don't have it and if you don't
i mean i don't know what to say you got
to go get yourself some of this because
it's magical you're missing out
as for the supposedly superior forms of
primitive air conditioning yeah before
air conditioning people in the hotter
areas of the world would sometimes live
under cliffs or in caves
the lady in the video laments that we're
no longer cave dwellers even though
there are still plenty of uninhabited
caves in the world and she's more than
free to take up residence in any one of
them where she can experience the pure
more organic form of cooling along with
the pure organic bats and spiders and
snakes who will all be her roommates i'm
sure
but do you know what people mainly did
before air conditioning
um they suffered and they sweat
and they smelled terrible one can assume
and they died of heat stroke a lot
it's true that domiciles of all types
were built back in those days to
accommodate the heat as best they could
whereas homes today are not built to
accommodate the heat because the
assumption is that we'll all have air
conditioning like civilized people but
emphasis is on the phrase as best they
could it was still very hot and
uncomfortable and gross and smelly
anyone who spent time in the warmer
parts of the world where air
conditioning is still scarce
can attest to that fact
but what we really see with this kind of
thing is how white supremacy
is so often recommended
by the people who are trying to condemn
it
now i don't believe that white supremacy
gave us air conditioning i believe that
credit goes to a guy named willis
carrier in pittsburgh in 1902
but if white supremacy did give us air
conditioning well then i guess that's at
least one good thing about white
supremacy
thank you white supremacy for that one i
guess
see the ironic consequence of tying
everything back to white supremacy is
that you end up making it sound like not
such a bad thing after all
the left now will blame white supremacy
for everything from air conditioning too
if you recall that graphic on the
smithsonian national museum of african
american history website a while back
they also blame it for hard work
objectivity rational thinking this is
all white supremacy
so does that mean that it's white
supremacy which enables us to sit in a
cool living room on a summer day and
have an interesting rational
conversation with our friends
that's not my claim
but would seem to be the claim of the
very people who imagine themselves to be
battling against white supremacy it's an
interesting combat strategy isn't it
white supremacy is evil and it's
everywhere and it's also the reason why
your home is comfortable and you aren't
dying of heat stroke
isn't this bad
i mean are you sure it's evil then
sounds kind of nice by your telling
the other problem of course is the
familiar one that the people complaining
about modern conveniences like air
conditioning
not just complaining about them but
labeling them wicked and racist and
deadly
most certainly do not forgo those
conveniences themselves
i could actually somewhat respect
someone who thinks that ac
is a nazi conspiracy
if they lived by those convictions and
chose to roast in the summertime or go
live in a vernacular mud hut under a
cliff or in a hole underground or
something
i can almost respect any principle maybe
not agree with it but respect it to some
degree if the person professing it also
endeavors to live according to it but
the people who allegedly hate all of the
technology bequeathed to them by western
civilization
never choose to forfeit any of it
they enjoy the luxury and comfort these
things provide to them while whining
about how evil and terrible all of it is
this is a far-reaching problem actually
in our society it's not just on the left
very few people really make any attempt
to live according to their professed
value systems which means that everybody
is arguing with each other and defending
world views that they don't really
subscribe to
and whose implications they don't
understand because they have never tried
to put it into practice
this is not just a problem with air
conditioning critics
but they are certainly among the most
egregious examples
and for that reason
i can declare from my cool climate
controlled studio
that they are all today canceled
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends